for a while now fans have speculated
that far cry 6 would bring back fan
favorite villain voss one of the
antagonists of far cry 3. voss is the
guy who pretty much defined what has
become the archetypal far cry villain
he's charismatic scary and ruthless and
he has some long and fun bad guy
monologues did i ever tell you the
definition
of insanity
hints that vos was returning have
circulated for more than a year with
actor michael mando even suggesting he'd
reprise the role and that's fueled a lot
of fan theories about his return in far
cry 6. ubisoft revealed earlier this
year that voss as well as far cry 4
villain pagan min and far cry 5 villain
joseph seed would be playable characters
in a far cry 6 post-launch dlc expansion
but as it turns out there's more to the
voss story than whatever is going on in
that expansion and at least some of the
fan's speculation was right brace
yourself because we're going to talk
about a far cry 6 post-credits scene and
there are spoilers for both far cry 6
and far cry 3 beyond and don't forget to
hit like and subscribe to gamespot for
more videos like this one the post
credit scene has no visuals just a metal
gear solid style blank screen where you
can hear two people having a
conversation one of those characters is
juan cortes the guerrilla mentor of
protagonist danny rojas the other sounds
like the voice of vos which raises a lot
of questions about how far cry 6 and far
cry 3 are linked and what the
post-credits scene is teasing for the
future libertad thanks you for your
support
and i come bearing good news
our riviera supply has tripled
ah
you know he's so sad about that castillo
kid i mean what is
wow that is crazy
a tragedy
well you know some people are just
seeking the mind that man
they're out of control
same time next week
you can bet your life on it
first let's debunk one fan theory that
speculated far cry 6 is set before far
cry 3 and would serve as a prequel that
theory went that 13 year old diego
castillo the son of anton and a major
character throughout the story would
actually grow up to become vas that
would allow far cry 6 to link to vasa's
life without dealing with the one big
issue about bringing the character back
voss died in far cry 3. the post-credits
scene makes it definitively clear that
voss and diego are not the same person
still we're left with a lot of questions
about how the two games are linked and
what the return of vos might mean so
let's talk about what's actually in the
post-credits scene from the sounds of
things juan is meeting vos for a
business deal juan says that deposing
castillo has tripled the production of
viviro the life-saving cancer drug yara
creates in the game vos seems to be his
black market contact juan is selling
viviro and voss is buying it since he's
a drug smuggler and a pirate in far cry
3 that all tracks what's not clear is
whether this scene and far cry 6 in
general take place before or after far
cry 3. if it's before then voss might
just be a smuggler selling viviro
sometime before he's killed in far cry 3
making far cry 6 a bit of a prequel but
if it's after that tells us that vos
must have survived his apparent demise
in fc3 that seems fully possible since
your battle with vos in that game was
already a strange dreamlike vision we
don't really get enough information in
far cry 6 to know for sure when that
story takes place so we can't be sure if
vos survived far cry 3 or not but if vas
is still alive this scene makes some
suggestions for the future of yara it
calls into question juan's motives as a
member of the libertad freedom fighters
which is something the game has already
done a couple of times along the way it
raises some possibilities about the idea
of dany's ally becoming a potential
enemy sometime in the future as multiple
forces vie for control of the country
and the lucrative vivero production
industry it also suggests that vas
remains something of a powerful criminal
and pirate possibly working for himself
now rather than serving a higher boss as
in far cry 3. we don't know much about
juan and vaz's relationship but their
shady dealings probably aren't good news
for a country that just overthrew a
dictator and is lacking a stable
government as for what's next for vos
and far cry it depends on whether the
character might be woven into far cry
6's story once you've finished the game
you can continue to play far cry 6
fighting castio's military holdouts new
targets spring up each week as you work
to root out the loyalists and along with
the aforementioned dlc expansion that
suggests we could see more of the story
of yara down the road since juan is
already interacting with vas he might be
part of that story and we could see him
turn up as a villain or in some other
capacity opposite dany in post-release
content then again the post-credits
scene could just be a tease for a new
far cry title and merely functions to
set up the fact that vos is alive out
there and smuggling drugs in any case
it's clear that there's more vos coming
to far cry in the future in some form or
another
you